ouais magdalena show devenick bonjour à
vous vous êtes vous dans un autre est un
voisin de l'ukraine vous êtes ans en
pologne des réfugiés affluent là encore
encore et toujours un
oui je suis allé chercher à la gare qui
fait point de kate pour les réfugiés qui
arrivent contre indirectement de l'ihf
vous pouvez le voir derrière moi il
serait que robuste devant la guerre pour
aller plus loin il ya le transport qui
les amène soit dans le ville grandes
villes de pologne où ils vont aller
ailleurs parce qu'il ya aussi des
transports qui vont les envoyer il va
les amener à l'étrangère par exemple en
estonie je rencontrais une famille
crânien qui va aller en italie aussi
donc il ya beaucoup de volontaires ici
beaucoup de gens qui aident à les
ukrainiens à se déplacer en pologne et
ailleurs aussi
magdalena comment est-ce qu'on a réagi
là vous vous trouvez à l'attack d'oeil à
vivre cette base militaire ciblée aux
premières heures du matin c'est à
quelques vingt kilomètres je crois de la
frontière
oui c'est vrai que je parlais avec des
citoyennes de pêcher mais il modifions
était très inquiet parce que avant pas
juste au début de cette invasion russe
en ukraine ils sont tous accusés y sont
concentrés surtout sur aide humanitaire
sur les réfugiés qu'ils arrivaient en
pologne mais maintenant qu'on l'a tech
était juste avant qu'il omet de la
frontière polonaise cette guerre dans le
sens militaire des liens les réalités
dont lanceur dans le sens de ce site
donc ils ont été très très inquiet mais
il continue à des légendes continue à
travailler continuent et continueront
quand ils ont déjà dit à aider et à
faire tout ce qu'ils peuvent pour est
près d'être ce qu'ils ont besoin
merci beaucoup à magdalena